السلام عليكم ورحمه الله قالت منظمه
هيومان رايتس واتش ان الاحكام في مصر ضد
صحفي قناه الجزيره لا تعد استثناء لان
ممارسه الصحافه في مصر اصبحت جريمه ولان
الدستور الذي يضمن حريه التعبير لا يحميها
نتوقف مع هذا الموضوع لنناقش في
محورين كيف تتعاطى النقابات والمؤسسات
الاعلاميه في مصر مع اعتقالات
الصحفيين وكيف تنعكس الاعتقالات
والملاحقات القضائيه على ظروف ممارسه
المهنه الصحفيه في
مصر الهيئات الدوليه والمنظمات الحقوقيه
والاعلاميه العالميه التي عبرت عن صدمتها
وامتعاضه من الاحكام بالسجن الصادره بحق
صحفي جزيره سرعان ما لفتت الانتباه الى ان
هذه الاحكام تخفي وراءها سجلا من اعتقال
الصحفيين وملاحقتهم في مصر منبهه الى ان
ابواب السجون اصبحت مشرعه امام حامل
الاقلام والكاميرات ممن كانوا يدافعون عن
حقهم في ممارسه مهنتهم غير ان كل ذلك يتم
اما وسط صمت مهني ومدني او باصوات محتشمه
اختفت وسط الوعود الرسميه باقامه دوله
القانون والمؤسسات
والحريات قتلت ميد اشرف في اذار مارس
الماضي كانت الصحفيه الشابه تغطي اشتباكات
بين قوات الامن ومتظاهرين مناوئين
للانقلاب عندما اصيبت برصاصه قاتله في
الراس كانت تلك اخر مهمه تقوم بها من دون
ان تعود الى مكاتب صحيفه
تها
الصحفي مراسلون بلا حدود اعتبرت مقتلها
جريمه يجب ان لا تمر من دون عقاب وقالت
انه ومنذ عزل الرئيس المنتخب محمد مرسي
اصبحت وسائل الاعلام تستهدف بشكل منهجي
وخاصه اثناء تغطيه المسيرات او المظاهرات
لم تكن مياد الوحيده فقد قتل زملاء اخرون
لها لا يقل عددهم عن عشره منذ الانقلاب
كما اصيب العشرات من بينهم خالد حسين الذي
يعمل في احد صحف خالد الش خالد الشهد خالد
اصيب خالد برصاصه مباشره في الصدر خلال
تفريق قوات الامن مظاهره امام جامعه
القاهره ولم يقتصر الامر على القتل او
الاصابه فثم ايضا مئات اعتقلوا لفترات
متقطعه او قصيره بينما يتواصل اعتقال نحو
50 اخرين في انتظار محاكمتهم يجري كل ذلك
وسط صمت يكاد يكون مطبقا من نقابه
الصحفيين المصريين فلا اعتصامات ولا دعوات
لمقاطعه تغطيه الاحداث الرسميه احتجاجا
على ما يجري لاعضائها وفي راي صحفيين
مستقلين فان الصمت القبور هذا قد يفسر كاص
فاف من قياده هذه النقابه الى جانب العهد
الجديد اضافه الى طغيان الاعتبارات
الايديولوجيه لدى هؤلاء ضد تيار الاسلام
السياسي ما يجعلهم يغمضون اعينهم عن
الانتهاكات المتواصله
فلماذا استقالت هذه النقابه من دورها وهي
التي كانت تقيم الدنيا وفق هؤلاء ولا
تقعدها في زمن مرسي او خلال السنوات
الاخيره من حكم مبارك سؤال يتكرر ايضا في
حاله مؤسسات يقع صحفييها ضحايا تعامل
السلطات مع الصحافه باعتبارها جريمه على
حد وصف هيومن رايتس وتش فترد على اعتقالهم
او حتى مقتلهم بالصمت او ببيان خجول كانهم
قتلوا في حادث سير وقع بالصدفه وخلفها بعض
الاساء ولمناقشة
والصحفي محمد منير ومن القاهره ايضا مجدي
حمدان عضو جبهه الانقاذ المصريه مرحبا
بضيوفنا الكرام استاذ صلاح
بدوي الاحكام
الاخيره الصادمه في حق صحفي الجزيره يعني
تبدو حسب بيانات الجهات الدوليه الكثيره
والعديده التي ادانت هذه الاحكام كشجره
اخفت غابه من انتهاكات والاعتقالات في حق
الصحفيين في مصر ما دلالت ذلك انا اعجبني
كلمه قالها الاستاذ مصطفى السوال اللي هو
المدير بالانابه لشبكه قنوات الجزيره قال
ايه قال هذا ليس حكما على صحفيه الجزيره
بل هو حكم على الصحافه جمعا وبالتالي
دلالتها انه اولا بالنسبه للقضيه المهنيه
ماحدش هيختلف فيها مؤيد او معارض بينا
كصحفي او كاعلام كلنا بنجرب عمليات حبس
الصحفيين او قتلهم او الاعتداء عليهم او
مصادره حريتهم دلالتها انه الثاني حاجه
انه الحكم اللي صدر ده حكم مسيس بالاساس م
لهش اي صبغه قانونيه باي شكل بالاكا هو
حكم انتقامي مسيس استهدف الجزيره وما تمثل
لانها تدافع عن الشرعيه في مصر وتدافع عن
حق الشعب المصري في ان طبعا نن ننطلق من
هذه الاحكام لنتحدث عن العمل الصحفي حقيقه
العمل الصحفي اليوم في مصر حقيقه العمل
الصحفي احنا منذ 3 يوليو من اول دقيقه قام
فيها الانقلاب استهدف الصحف واستهدف وسائل
الاعلام والقنوات ساعتها اسست حركه صحفيون
ضد الانقلاب العسكري وهي حركه بتضم صحفيون
واعلاميون وعددها حاليا يقترب من 200000
واحد لان بتضم اعلاميين الى جانب الصحفيين
لان ادركنا خطوره ما يحدث من اول اغلاق
الفضائيات كل الفضائيات اللي بتعارض
الانقلاب تم اغلاقها كل الصحف اللي بتعارض
الانقلاب تم اغلاقها واخرها جريده الحريه
والعداله وجريده الشعب وال تم اعتقال
غالبيه الناشطين والاعلاميين ال البارزين
والصحفيين البارزين في تلك الصحف واداع
السجون والوضع تم قتل الصحفيين تم مصادره
دور نقابه الصحفيين لم يعد لنقابه
الصحفيين المصريين تقديركم تقديركم لعدد
الصحفيين المعتقلين الان في مصر
خل في احصاء عملناه انه منذ 3 يوليو هو
منذ انقلاب 3 يوليو تم اعتقال ما يقرب من
90 صحفي وتم قتل حوالي 14 صحفي نعم من هنا
يعني انتقل الى محمد منير يعني حوالي 90
صحفي ومقتل اعداد كبيره جدا جدا منهم بعد
الانقلاب ومع ذلك لا نكاد نسمع اصوات
الهيئات الصحفيه المؤسسات الصحفيه نقابات
الصحفيين المصريين وا زملاء المهنه
يتحدثون لن نسمع لهم صوتا عاليا يتحدثون
عن هذه انتهاكات او يدينون
لماذا يا سيدي اكبر دليل على ان حيرك
الموضوع
غير الن
في بعد الحكم على الصحفيين الجزيره يا
استاذ محمد
منير لو تع جوابك من فضلك لان صوتك لم يكن
في بدايه
مسموعا يعني يعني كده
كده كده سامعني لكنه يبدو بعيدا يعني لا
اعلى حاجه عندي من كدهه عندك في ال طيب
تفضل الان الان على الاقل على الاقل يعني
نكاد نفهم ما تقول نعم افضل اه يعني الان
الدنيا في مصر في المجتمع الاعلامي
المجتمع الصحفي في حاله ثوره شديده بعد
الاحكام على صحفيين الجزيره ولم يميز
الصحفيين المصريين بين كونه صحفي للجزيره
التي تتعارض مع اتجاه كثير من الصحفيين
المصريين او صحفي في اي مكان اخر
الفكره اننا بنرى ان في هذا الحكم انتهاك
لحريه الصحافه بصفه عامه حيه الصحافه التي
دفعت عنها نقابه الصحفيين ولم تفرق بين
الصحفي حكومي والصحفي معارض واعتبرت ان اي
صحفي بيمثل اي اتجاه او بيعمل مع
اي قناه او او بيعمل مع اي صحيفه لها وجهه
نظر معارضه مجرد حبس الصحفي هو جريمه في
حق الاعلام كله طيب استاذ محمد منير يعني
انا امامي لائحه بالعديد من الاسماء
الصحفيين المعتقلين طبعا انا لي لدي
الاسماء كلها ولكن حوالي 53 اسم لحد الان
يعني تواريخ احتجازهم والمؤسسات التي يعني
يعملون لديها يعني الاحظ هنا مثلا هاني
صلاح الدين وهو ينتمي الى صحيفه اليوم
السابع و واعتقل ولكن لا يبدو ان مؤسسته
سندته انت تعمل في اليوم
السابع يا سيدي لس انت تتحدث معي مصادقه
وكان قد صدر قرار اداري من المجلس الاعلى
بوق تحقات الاستاذ هاني صلاح الدين له
مستحقات طبيعه لمجلس الاعلى وتدخلنا امس
واعدنا هذه المستحقات اهه مره تانيه
القضيه احنا احنا نتعامل مع زميل صحفي
ماليش علاقه هو بيمثل انهي
اتجاه جريده اليوم السابع لم تتخذ اي
اجراء تجاه الاستاذ هاني صلاح الديب ا او
اجراء
سلبي نقابه الصحفيين مازالت ترس له حتى
الان المحامين وما زال نقيب الصحفيين بيبض
الجهد لتحسين اوضاع حبسهم داخل السجود اما
التدخل في القضيه فانت تعلا ت انه لا
يم للاسف انقطع الصوت محمد منير نتحول الى
مجدي حمدان وهو عضو جبهه القاذ المصريه
معنا من القاهره استاذ مجدي
حمدان يعني ونحن ننظر الى هذه القائمه
العارضه والطويله للصحفي المعتقلين او
الصحفيين الذين قتلوا او هذه الاحكام
الجائره والصادم التي صدرت في حق الصحفيه
الجزيره وخلفت ردود فعل غاضبه من مختلف
هيئات الدوليه سواء كانت حكومات او منظمات
هل نتساءل هنا هل هذا هو التطبيق العملي
بالوعود التي اطلقها النظام الجديد في مصر
بعد الانقلاب لصون الحريات العامه ومن
بينها طبعا حريه
الاعلام بالطبع بالنسبه لي انا ارى ان هذا
الحكم هو صادم في المقام الاول وكنت اتمنى
ان يقوم رئيس المحكمه الموقر بترحيل
الصحفيين او استبعادهم خارج القاهره لا
ادار احكام لان اللي انا شفته من ادله
الاتهام هو ادله الاتهام كان كانت عباره
عن خمس تهم موجهه الى كل من تواجد داخل
القفص او من تم القبض عليه في خليه ماريوس
لكن في يعني مع احترامي لدوله القانون
وسياده القانون المصري فلو كان هناك تدخل
من الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي لكان قيل ان
عبد الفتاح السيسي يملي ارادته على القضاء
المصري لكنه رجل صر اليوم واكدها اليوم في
مؤتمر صحفي بانه لا يتدخل وانه اتصل بوزير
العد شخصيا واكد له انه لا تدخل وانه
عندما التقى بالوفد الايطالي اكد ايضا انه
لا يتدخل في السلطه القضائيه وان السلطه
القضائيه لديها ادواتها ولدينا الان
الكثير من درجات التقاضي فلا نستعجل
الامور هذا حكم هذا هو حكم اول درجه هناك
ثاني درجه وثالث درك ل نستجم ربما يتم
تخفيف الاحكام ربما يتم الافراج عنهم يعني
لا لا نريد ان نعطي للقضيه اكثر من من
واليها او من حجمها الطبيعي انا لا اتحدث
هنا استاذ استاذ مجدي حمدان لا اتحدث هنا
فقط عن صحفي الجزيره ولكن هناك انا كما
قلت في البدايه صحفي الجزيره وقضيتهم
والاحكام الجائره في حقهم هي لم تمثل سوى
شجره تخفي غابه من الانتهاكات غابه من
الاعتقالات غابه من اسماء يعني اعداد
كبيره جدا من الصحفيين وبنهم يعني صحفيون
كانوا يؤيدون الانقلاب وهم الان وراء
القطبان سيدي الفاضل القضيه ايضا قضيه
مريوت كان بها انس محمد البلتا وتم
الاخراج عنه اخذ براءه يعني الموضوع ليس
به
لكنها ادوات توضع امام القاضي فيقوم
باصدار حكمه بناء على هذه الادوات يعني
خلينا لا نقول ان م صلاح صلاح البديوي
يعني صحيح ان هناك انتقادات لعمل الجهاز
القضائي وانتقاد ايضا لاداء النقابه
والمنظمات الحقوقيه التي ينظر على انها
ربما لم لم تكن في مستوى التحدي لم تقم
بواج واجباتها اتجاه الصحفيين وحقوقهم
ولكن اين دور وسائل اعلام بحدي ذاتها
وواجباتها اتجاه الصحفيين وحريه الاعلام
يعني هؤلاء زملاء هؤلاء زملاء لهم وسائل
الاعلام تقصدها في مصر داخل مصر بالتحديد
سيد الفاضل لم يعد هناك لم يعد هناك وسائل
اعلام الان في مصر منذ الثالث من يوليو
اصبح في صحافه وسائل اعلام دعائيه لصالح
الانقلاب وعمليته السياسيه وما ترتب عليه
تلك الوسائل قد ثمت المصريين الى شعبين
وهددت الامن القومي المصري وضربته في مقتل
شعب تصادر حرياته ويقتل متهم بالارهاب ولا
حقوق قانونيه له ولا صحف تعبر عنه ولا
وسائل اعلام تعبر عنه وشعب اخر عندما
عندما يتعرض لاي ضغط او اي شيء تتحرك تلك
الوسائل للدفاع عنه بقدر الامكان وايضا
نقابه الصحفيين نفس النمط قسمت الصحفيين
الى شعبين شعب يتم تتحرك عندما ولاخر
عندما قتلت الاخت التي تم قتلها وعلى فكره
وتعرف مين اللي قتلها زميلتها شهدت مين
اللي قتلها وشافوا مين اللي قتلها والشرطه
اللي قتلتها ماذا فعل نقيب الصحفيين في
مواجهه قتلها ماذا فعل في مواجهه 14 صحفي
قتل من قبل لا شيء ماذا فعل في اتهام صحفي
بالتقابل لصالح حماس ده احنا عندنا واحد
اسمه ابراهيم الدراوي زميلنا متهم ح بال
التقاب لصالح حماس وممكن ياخذ اعدام او
ممكن ياخذ يعملوا في اي حاجه فذا انا اريد
ان افهم يعني اريد ان افهم وهذا السؤال
سالته طرحته على مجدي حمدان ولم اجد جوابا
يعني قد نفهم ان الصحفيين ربما يتهمون
بانهم كانوا يدافعون عن مرحله سيس مرحله
مرسي وانتقدوا الانقلاب ولكن ان يتم الزج
في السجون
بصحفي ينتمون الى مؤسسات يعني دعمت
الانقلاب وصحفيون دعموا الانقلاب وهم الان
وراء القضبان كيف نفهم ذلك يا سيدي نحن
نواجه ثوره مضاده الثوره المضاده ت
استهدفت كل ثوار 25 يناير عمود الفقر بتاع
السوار ال 25 التيار الاسلامي وفي قلب
الاخوان المسلمين عندما يتم كسر هذا هذا
العمود وضربه يسهل التخلص من النتوءات
وهذا كلام قلته من قبل 1000 مره الانقلاب
اكل خصومه الاساسيين سو يحاول اكل خصومه
الاساسيين وبعدها سيعدل على البقيه التي
ايدته من سور 25 يناير هذا انقلاب وهذا
ثوره مضاده ان اردت ان تعرف التوصيف
الصحيح فهو لن يترك حر اي صحفي حر لن
يتركه السيد محمد منير هيومان رايتس واتش
يعني تقول بان الحمايه الدستوريه للصحفيين
لا تساوي الورق الذي كت عليه هل هنا نحن
امام المشكله في النظام الحالي والقوانين
السائده ام في الجسم الصحفي الذي يفترض به
انه اذا اشتكى منه عضو تدع له سائر الجسد
بالسهر
والحمى يا سيدي انا ملاحظ من بدايه الحلقه
ان ان هناك محاوله لتفريق الجماعه الصحفيه
الى جماعه مع الانقلاب وجماعه ضد الانقلاب
ومحاوله فرض اتجاه سياسي معين عليهم
تسمعني يا سيدي اسمعك جيدا اتفضل
اه الحق يعني الجماعه الصحفيه لها طبيعه
خاصه في مصر وزميل الاستاذ صلاح بديوي
يعلم هذا تماما نحن لا نسمح بالاعتداء على
زميل صحفي بسبب عمله بين كان اتجاهه لو
كلف زميلي الاستاذ صلاح بديوي نفسه دقيقه
واحده وسيادتك كلفت نفسك ودخلت على موقع
اليوم السابع اللي حضرتك قلت من شويه ان
مش مهتم هتلاقي فيه 15 خبر بيستعرض بشكل
موضع موضوعي الاحتجاجات الشديده على الحكم
على الصحفيين الجزيره بصرف النظر عن اتجاه
السياسي لجريده اليوم السابع الفكره احنا
دلوقتي بنحاول نجمع نفسنا لحمايه هؤلاء
الصحفيين ولحمايه فكره حريه الصحافه في
مصر مش اقعد افرق هذا انقلابي وهذا حكومي
وهذا غير ذلك نحن نحن بنادين ادانه شديده
ده بوضوح الحكم على الصحفيين الجزيره
واللي هيقول ان ده قانون اذا كان خرج بعض
الصحفيين الموالين للحكم بيقولوا ان ده
حكم قضائي ولا يجب الضغط عليه بقول لهم ان
هناك تداخل بين الاحكام القضائيه والسياسه
طول الوقت انور السدات حكم عليه قضائيا ثم
تبين ان هو بطل وطني بعد ذلك
ا نيرسو منديله حكم عليه قضائيا فكره ان
الحكم القضائي منزه عن الانتقاد في
السياسي او المنزع في التداخل دي فكره
ساذجه ولهذا سنناقش سنناقش بعد الفاصل
استاذ محمد منير سنناقش لهذا سنناقش بعد
الفاصل كيف ستنعكس هذه الاعتقالات
والملاحقات القضائيه على ظروف ممارسه
المهنه الصحافيه في مصر فنرجو ان تبقى
معنا مشاهدينا
الكرام اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش واقع الحريات الصحفيه
في مصر بعد احكام الجائره التي صدرت في حق
صحفي
الجزيره معنا ضيوفنا من القاهره محمد منير
و وهو عض وهو الكاتب الصحفي كان معنا في
الجزء الاول مجدي حمدان عضو جبهه القاده
مصريه وانضم الينا الان عمر هاشم ربيع
نائب مدير الدراسه الاستراتيجيه في
القاهره ومعنا هنا في الاستديو الاستاذ
صلاح بديوي مؤسس مؤسس ومنسق حركه صحفيون
ضد الانقلاب العسكري في مصر استاذ عمرو
هاشم ربيع لعل السؤال الذي يطرح كثيرا
الان هو اذا كانت الديمقراطيه تقاس
بمدى الحريات الموجوده في البلدان التي
تعيشها يعني كيف يمكن ان نفهم هذه الاحكام
الصادره في حق الصحفيين واي رساله سترسلها
هذه الاحكام الصادمه والملاحقات المستمره
للصحفيين سواء للصحفيين متممين الجزيره او
الصحفيين المصريين عموما والذي يقدر عددهم
بحوالي 90 صحفيا معتقلا
الان نعم استاذ عبد الصمد شوف مع كل يعني
يعني تحفظي على الاسلوب الذي تعمل به
الجزيره بشكل خاص وقطر بشكل عام مع
الاحداث في مصر وما تمارسه من دعايا سوداء
هذا موضوع لكن بالتاكيد ان هذه الاحكام هي
احكام سالبه للحريه بمعنى ان تقو حريه
الراي والتعبير وتصور ان هذا المناخ لا
يستقيم
في مع الحكم الجديد طيب هذا المناخ لا
يستقيم وهذه الاحكام جائر اي يعني كما
اعترفت بها كل المنظمات الحقوقيه اي رساله
سترسلها هذه الاحكام وهذا التعامل مع
العمل الصحفي ومع الصحفيين عن مصر اليوم
عن نظام مصر اليوم وصورته امام العالم
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد بترسل رساله سلبيه لكن
انا اولا لم نرى حت رساله سلبيه وهي وهي
ماذا ان هناك مناخ من تقويه حريه الراي
والتعبد اعتبر انها عقوبه سالبه للحريه
ومن ثم فان لكن لم نرى ولم لم نقرا حتى
الان حيثيات الحكم ولم تعلن حتى الان
اتصور انها بعد عده ايام قليله سوف تعلن
الامر الامر الثاني ان هذه الاحكام مستانف
عليها يعني خاضعه للاستئناف ثانيا او
ثالثا ان معظم المحكوم عليهم كان محكوم
عليهم غيابيا ومن ثم سوف يعد سوف يعد
محاكمتهم مره اخرى لكن دائما ما بتستغل
مثل هذه الاحكام باعتبارها انها موجهه
موجهه لحريه الراي والتعبير دائما
على اعتبار انها احكام نافذه
واحكام تنفذ من وقتها
وضد يعني ف يعني استغلت باستغلال ايضا
بشكل اخر لذلك يعني اتصور ان الرئيس عليه
وفقا لصلاحياته في الماده 155 من الدستور
انه ياخذ المبادره ويصدر عفو عن المحكوم
عليهم وان كان هذا الامر بالتاكيد سوف
يكون بعد اصدار احكام باته ونهائيه يعني
انا سالت سابقا هذا السؤال واريد اطرحه
مره اخرى بخصوص هؤلاء الصحفيين الذين
كانوا ذراعا اعلاميا اذا شئنا ان نقول
للانقلاب وروجوا له وسووا له ومع ذلك الان
هم في سجون يعني ما ما تفسير ذلك
برايك لا هو طبعا من البدايه ما بحبش انا
اقول كلمه انقلاب والا بقول لك ان نصبح
هنا طرف يعني لست القضيه هنا المسه وتصبح
جزء من الدعايه السوداء
يعني اتحفظ على هذه الكلمه لا اتمنى ان
تكون محاور ولا تكون طرف على كل بغض النظر
لكن مثل هذه الاحكام زي ما سبق قلت لك
الاخ عبد الصمد هي سالبه للحريه بالتاكيد
واحكام لا يمكن باي حال من الاحوال ان
تكون مؤيده او مؤيده او يعني بيتم
الموافقه عليها من اي من انصار حقوق
الانسان
والداعين الى وجود حكم ديمقراطي سليم مبني
على احترام حقوق الانسان بالت ط ينضم
الينا شكرا لك على كل حال ا عمر هاشم ربيع
ينضم الينا ايضا محمود عطيه ومنسق اتلاف
مصر فوق الجميع من القاهره استاذ محمود
عطيه اي افق ما زال للعمل الصحفي في مصر
اليوم اذا توزع اما اظهار الولاء المطلق
للنظام بما يسمح بما يمسخ عفوا يمسخ هويه
الصحفي ومهنته
او ان ان يكون سيف العقوبات فوق قبه
الصحفي كل صحفي
مهني
محم مء مساء الخير يا استاذ عبد الصمد
مساء
الخير الموضوع اللي حضرتك بتتكلم فيه وال
والزملاء
السابقين اللي اتكلموا فيه المحور بتاعه
الاحكام اللي حصلت امس او اول امس من على
الصحفيين لا احدث فقط عن الاحكام الصادره
في حق صحفي جزيره وانما افتح يعني ملف
الصحفيين والعمل الصحفي وه ملف هؤلاء
المعتقلين بالعشرات الان في السجون
المصريه من بينهم حتى من كان يؤيد
الانقلاب اوصل بس اوصل اوصل الفكره بتاعتي
يا استاذ ع الصمد اوصل الفكره عايزين نفصل
ما بين الصحفيين وقناه الجزيره تمام و
والاحكام
اولا الاحكام القضائيه ا في ما سبق احد
سمعته بيقول ان يعني ايه ما فيش تعليق على
الاحكام القضائيه القضيه اللي حصلت ما هي
دي لب الموضوع ان الاخوه اللي دخلوا دول
دخلوا بتاشيره سياحيه واستجار غرفه في
فندق الماروت يعني هذا مش موضوع يا سي
محمود عطيه بالله يا سي محمود عط انا هذا
ليس موضوعي انا هنا اتحدث والوقت ضيق جدا
امامي بدع دقائق اتحدث عن الوضع الصحفيين
المعتقلين الان وراء السجون في مصر ومنهم
كما قلت من كان يؤيد السلطه الحاكمه الان
لا لا لا تخم ده ده كلام كل مافيش حد
معتقل مافيش حد كل اللي يا سيدي انا امامي
لائحه لائحه من الاسماء لائحه من الاسماء
حوالي 53 اسم وكل تاريخ واعتقاله والمؤسسه
التي ينتمي اليها مش حضرتك بتسالني مش
حضرتك بتسالني سيبني ار مش انت حك وتسالني
يا استاذ عبد
الصمد يا سيدي فاضل دول كل دول من امر من
النيابه العامه احيله بامر من النيابه
العامه وانا راجل محامي وبكلمك ده احيله
ايوه ان شاء الله ترفع 100 ورقه زي دول يا
استاذ عبد الصمد طيب شكرا لك يا محمود
عطيه شكرا لك لان الوقت ضيق تعليق اخير
استاذ باختصار شديد جدا باختصار باسم
الحركه حركه صحفيين ضد الانقلاب العسكري
انا بحيي قناه الجزيره اللي تركت صحفييها
الان وبتداولات
ث انيه انه اللي بيحصل بالضبط عشان تبقى
عارف القضاء المصري هيكله كله ممتاز
ونحترمه ولكن في دوائر منتقاه انا تحبس
سنتين وبقول لك بينطقوا دوائر تلك الدوائر
المنتقاه جزء من الانقلاب توظف في حبس
الصحفيين توظف في اصدار احكام بالاعدام
وللاسف رغم قلتها فانها تسيء الى القضاء
المصري وتشوه سمعته تماما وتجعل العالم
كله يفقد مصداقيته وثقته فيه شكرا لك صلاح
بديوي مؤسس ومنسق حركه صحفيون وضد
الانقلاب في مصر نشكر ايضا ضيف
من القاهره محمد منير الكاتب والصحفي ومن
القاهره ايضا كان معنا مجدي حمدان عضو
جبهه انقاذ المصريه ثم انضم الينا عمرو
هاشم مدير الدراسات استراتيجيه في القاهره
من القاهره ومحمود
عطيه منسق ائتلاف مصر فوق الجميع شكرا
لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء بحول
الله
ه